[Musique]
en 2014 j'ai fait une première tentative
de suicide
j'avais 20 ans j'ai été hospitalisée en
psychiatrie sa sortie de l'hôpital géré
fait une tentative de suicide j'y suis
retourné une détresse profonde le rouge
depuis plus de cinq ans il a suivi tous
les traitements proposés par les
spécialistes il voulait y croire
médicaments psychothérapie diverses
électrochoc
rien n'y fait le mal est toujours là je
sais vraiment comment le formuler mais
c'est c'est l'angoissé c'est l'isolément
le le retrait par rapport aux autres je
veux la préférons l'apologie de
l'euthanasie mais à mes yeux pour moi
l'euthanasie c'est en soi même si
c'était le dernier
c'est aujourd'hui le soin que je réclame
la loi belge permet en principe l'accès
à l'euthanasie pour des personnes en
détresse psychique comme robin mais il
leur faut obtenir l'accord formel de
deux médecins dont au moins un
psychiatre et les médecins sont
réticents à consentir à sa demande à
cause de son jeune âge qu'est ce que tu
vois dans le futur par rapport justement
à ces rencontres avec les médecins ou en
études j'ai pas encore eu de réponse ni
de nom ni le oui mais en tout cas ce que
je me sens écoutée
je vois que c'est envisageable
jacqueline et remords cette avocate et
présidente de l'association belge pour
le droit à mourir dans la dignité
elle est en contact régulier avec robert
la situation de romain est plus délicate
compte tenu de son âge et les difficile
pour un médecin ou pour toute autre
personne de se dire que à 25 ans la vis
c'est terminé jacqueline herremans c'est
aussi membre de la commission belge de
contrôle de la loi sur l'euthanasie
adoptée en 2002 cette loi stipule que le
critère de base pour l'accès à
l'euthanasie est l'infection grave et
incurable d'une maladie qu'elle soit
physique
ou psychique je comprends que cette
question pose débat et qu' il s'agit
pour ces patients d'être encore plus
prudent par rapport à une demande
d'euthanasie
[Musique]
deux ans après son départ j'ai compris
que j'ai failli dans l' écoute de ma vie
dit la fille de pierre polvent inc s'est
suicidé après 18 ans de souffrance
psychique et c'est tranché la gorge dans
sa chambre à l'institut psychiatrique où
elle était soignée elle demandait
pourtant l'aide médicale à mourir depuis
des années la loi était en place mais
son entourage résister à cette idée
objectivement j'ai péché comme les
médecins par acharnement affectif au
lieu d'entendre le message ma fille moi
je n'avais qu'un objectif c'est la
maintenir en vie
quel que soit le pli que el pais c'était
un comportement à mon avis très égoïste
l'euthanasie est largement acceptée par
la population en belgique en 2018
on en a pratiqué plus de 2300 de ce
nombre une cinquantaine seulement
étaient des cas d'euthanasie pour
souffrance psychique donné la mort à
quelqu'un c'est quand même franchir un
tabou majeur même si moi je ne me suis
jamais pris pour un assassin du mercy
ailleurs parce que quand je serai le
plus grand tueur de la province mais
j'ai toujours considéré que c'était un
soin ultime
le docteur luc sauveur affirme avoir
pratiqué des centaines de thann asie
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
toujours pour des cas de maladies
physiques connus et bien défini
j'appelle ça mourir vivant c'est les
patients qui était vivant jusqu'à la
dernière seconde et qui nous faisait
alesi docteur vous pouvez injecté et
l'injecté à la seringue en se regardant
les yeux dans les yeux dans le cas des
maladies psychiques que j'aimerais qu'on
me donnait un peu votre répression
c'est de toute façon beaucoup plus
complexe ça je pense les patients
atteints de maladies psychiques souvent
ont quand même une appréhension des
réalités qui est un peu différente dans
tout ce qui est psychique qui va vers la
psychose et c'est donc ça c'est quand
même compliqué une des premières
conditions que nous devons examiner
c'est la compétence de la personne faut
que la personne soit capable de prendre
une décision le docteur paul cosyns et
coprésident du comité consultatif belge
de bioéthique et spécialiste des
questions d'éthique médicale
il considère que la loi actuelle est
satisfaisante mais conseille à ses
collègues d'être plus exigeants et
d'ajouter des mesures de prudence
nous sommes par exemple d'avis que dans
les cas de malades de patients
psychiatriques il faut qu'il y ait au
moins deux psychiatres et pas un seul
comme prévu par la loi
il y apportant des contestations tout
récemment une famille a poursuivi devant
les tribunaux trois médecins après
d'utah nazis d'une jeune femme autiste
et borderline
la psychologue et psychanalyste ariane
base en a témoigné pour la famille dans
ce procès moi je dirais que l'euthanasie
pour raisons psychiques
ce n'est pas possible c'est à dire c'est
ça va à l'encontre de la loi la loi
demande une souffrance insoutenable ça
je pense l autorité du patient c'est
subjectif une maladie incurable et que
la souffrance insoutenable soit dû à la
maladie incurable je pense que la
médecine n'est pas capable d'objectiver
l'incurabilité desdites maladies
psychiques en belgique l'utah nazis pour
malades psychiques n'est autorisé que
lorsque toutes les options de traitement
ont été épuisés et que le patient
désespéré a fait des demandes répétées
je vous cacherais pas que j'ai eu
plusieurs cas de demandes d'euthanasie
de personnes psychiatrique qui on est
reçu un avis favorable et où la personne
n'a jamais demandé l'euthanasie qui ne
s'est jamais produite
mais la personne était soulagé de savoir
que si sa faune au pire encore il ya
moyen
le père d'edith vink parce que sa fille
pourrait être encore vivante
si elle avait eu droit à l'euthanasie
le simple fait d'avoir été reconnue dans
sa souffrance
le simple fait de lui avoir démontré
très clairement qu'elle n'était pas
responsable de sa souffrance
j'espère que ça leur ait donné des ailes
pour donner une dernière chance à la vie
pour remet la situation est tout autre
les effets secondaires des médicaments
qui continuent à prendre mais qui ne
soulagent plus sont devenues
insupportables les prochains mois je
l'espère cours avec une euthanasie
accordé
rapidement maintenant voilà si
l'euthanasie mais refuse et je pense que
je ne pense pas je suis sûr que je veux
je passerai à l'acte suicidaire oui
c'est vraiment bouleversant silva et on
voit à quel point c'est un dossier
complexe
est ce qu a eu des remises en question
de la loi en belgique pour ces cas de
maladie mentale dans la rue mais très
peu il ya eu des groupes religieux
minoritaires qui ont fait des pressions
quand cette loi était adoptée mais qui
sont amusés avec le temps il ya eu ici
ce procès qui a beaucoup fait jaser en
belgique d'une famille qui contestait
une zone asie de cette femme qui était
donc malade et qu'il y avait un
diagnostic d'autisme
mais comme les médecins ont été
acquittés dans cette cause il était
accusé d'homicides ça probablement que
ça aucun effet en belgique sur la
pratique du corps médical comme tel mais
a quand même des critères qui sont bien
établis ah oui à des critères très
important et qui existe en fait pour les
maladies somatiques comme pour les
maladies psychiatriques en particulier
il faut que la maladie soit incurable et
que la demande d'euthanasie soit fait
par une personne qui est parfaitement
consciente de ce que ça veut dire
et donc ça exclut d'office les maladies
psychiatriques comme les psychoses il ya
perte de conscience avec les réalités ça
exclut aussi les différentes formes de
démence comme l'examen par exemple où
les personnes ne peuvent pas demander
selon cette loi à l'avance en prévision
d'une perte de conscience si je vais je
voudrais que on procède à une euthanasie
dans le futur nom il faut que ce soit
fait au moment où on demande de manière
consciente et que la personne moment où
ces pratiques et soient encore
consciente de ce qui lui arrive
ce qui fait qu'au final les personnes
qui ont eu droit en belgique à cet état
nazi pour troubles psychiques selon des
personnes qui était en dépression
profonde en général d'eco borderline par
exemple ce qui exclut souvent des gens
comme romain qu'on voyait dans le
reportage qui malgré les tentatives de
suicide ont pas réussi à démontrer que
toutes les
solution tous les médicaments toutes les
psychothérapies ont pu être utilisés et
démontré leur inefficacité
c'est le critère déterminant en fait qui
fait qu'on n'ait accès même pour les
jeunes a même pour les mineurs les
mineurs c'est autorisé et on a vu dans
votre reportage à quel point c'est
délicat aussi pour les psychiatres qui
sont très prudents au niveau vraiment au
cas par cas
exact et les psychiatres ont tendance à
rajouter des conditions des mesures
depuis de prudence qui ne sont même pas
prévu dans la loi comme en particulier
demande de formel l'implication d'un
deuxième psychiatre qui revient à dire
trois médecins avant d'arriver à une
décision déterminante
il demande aussi que les délais soient
prolongées entre le moment où la demande
est faite et l'exécution comme tel de
l'utah nazis la loi prévoit un mois le
juge que c'est insuffisant qu'il faut
aller au delà de ça donc toutes sortes
de réflexion qui seront importantes
cette expérience belge pourrait être
mise à profit au québec car les
audiences se traite se tiendront
prochainement et que la loi sur les
musées aussi sur le plan fédéral donc à
retenir l'exemple de ce qu'ils ont
vraiment l'expérience de tout ça depuis
longtemps merci beaucoup sylvain non
plus